Seema Herman's vaping habit nearly
killed her just weeks ago she was placed
in a medically induced coma her lungs
had failed it seemed so simple and like
just a vaporizer it didn't seem like it
was hurting my lungs at all and I didn't
really consider myself a smoker either
how about the state she was so shocked
she filmed it my baby at 18 has worse
lungs than people that are dying on
ventilators how did that happen in two
years of use of the nicotine bait it's
not okay I thought if there's some
miracle that they could save her when
she gets out of this I want her to see
exactly what's happening and i
snapchatted the entire thing did you
fear that you wouldn't make it I mean
they didn't think I was gonna make it
she'd been vaping for two years and her
story is not unique
in the u.s. there are over 1,000
reported cases of lung illness linked
with e-cigarettes and at least 18 deaths
it is a matter of life and death and I
say to all of my patients the best thing
you can do was quit smoking when dr.
Katherine melamed first saw Seema she
thought it was pneumonia so right now
we're looking at Simas chest x-ray when
she came into the hospital see here a
profound change so you have inflammation
throughout both of her lungs and this
change in just 48 hours from just a
small abnormality to a profound
abnormality is quite shocking the vaping
liquid is heated and aerosolized and
then inhaled and then the lung is seeing
part of that product as a foreign
substance and then putting up a response
to attack it so sending white blood
cells in inflammatory markers and with
that comes a lot of fluid it's hard to
exchange oxygen and I think that's the
problem that we're seeing like many
other teenagers she was suffering from
nausea and shortness of breath the Trump
administration says it now plans to ban
what they think draws people in what do
you think about banning flavored
rats I think it's amazing I think that
it's definitely what started me for
smoking and all of my friends - I think
that all of their advertising is
definitely like more focused towards
younger people and I think that it'll
definitely stop the majority of the
people from smoking
jool dominates the US market in
e-cigarettes and some lawmakers want
their products pulled but not everyone
is convinced about a clampdown on flavor
banning flavors is going to create a
black market drug dealers are now going
to started selling flavored nicotine
products here they say it the black
market in THC the active ingredient in
cannabis which Seema also smoked that's
part of the problem not what they sell
those were THC that was unregulated in
anyway suspended in vitamin E acetate as
opposed to what we have which is e
liquid suspended in propylene glycol and
vegetable glycerin which are known to be
safer but no one has all the answers yet
and a generation of young people is
already hooked
Cordelia lynch skinnies los angeles
california